y
[Música]
este lunes el parlamento francés votará
el proyecto que podría convertir los
procesos sanitarios en pasaportes de
vacunación previo a la decisión y en
medio del rechazo de los anti vacunas se
han reportado amenazas a representantes
legislativos
entró en vigor el mayor acuerdo de libre
comercio del mundo el pacto de
asociación económica integral regional
de asia-pacífico abarca 5 en las 15
naciones que representan cerca del 30
por ciento de la población del planeta
un incendio se desató en el parlamento
de sudáfrica ubicado en ciudad del cabo
dejándolo totalmente destruido según
autoridades de causas por confirmarse la
conflagración afectó a algunas zonas del
complejo pero no se reportaron heridos
actualizamos la información en france de
24 yo soy daniel hablando tras superar
la cifra de los 10 millones de contagios
de kobe de 19 en francia- los diputados
galos se disponen a estudiar el lunes un
proyecto de ley que puede convertir el
pase sanitario en uno de vacunas aunque
todo apunta aunque sé que sería aprobado
el tema ha provocado rechazo de los
sectores anti vacunas con un aumento de
las amenazas hacia los diputados
esta es la escena con la que se despertó
pascal boas el miércoles cuando salió a
buscar su coche por la mañana
parecía una pesadilla o una película es
realmente mi coche
el diputado galo del partido la
repubblica en marcha de manuel macrón
también se encontró con amenazas
etiquetadas en la pared de su casa con
el mensaje vota no una probable
referencia al pase vacunal que se está
tramitando en la asamblea francesa
en democracia se puede estar en
desacuerdo pero hay otras formas de
expresarse en unos 5 millones de
franceses elegibles a la vacuna aún no
han recibido ni una sola dosis mientras
que el gobierno planea convertir la
tarjeta sanitaria de francia en una
tarjeta de vacunación que permitiría
sólo a los totalmente vacunados tener
acceso a sitios públicos un número
creciente de diputados en particular del
partido la república en marcha han
recibido amenazas o correos de odio de
un sector radical antivacunas voy a leer
un mensaje que he recibido hoy si no
votas no al proyecto de ley frank se
recordará la asamblea nacional como un
gigantesco año de sangre para este tipo
de intimidación no tiene cabida en
nuestra república la presidenta del
grupo de la república en marcha en la
asamblea nacional aurore verge también
recibió amenazas y ha pedido penas
severas acordes con la gravedad de las
intimidaciones mientras tanto la
respuesta del gobierno fue proporcionar
más seguridad a los diputados mientras
examinan el proyecto de ley sobre el
pase de vacunas con patrullas policiales
en el exterior de sus despachos así como
en sus domicilios
seguimos hablando de la pandemia porque
israel detectó su primer caso de
contagio simultáneo de coronavirus e
influencia influenza un fenómeno
conocido como flor ona y que fue
identificado por primera vez en eeuu
durante el primer año de pandemia para
conversar sobre este tema está con
nosotros carlos álvarez él es médico
infectólogo y coordinador de estudios de
kobe de 19 de la organización mundial de
la salud para colombianos señor carlos
muchas gracias por acompañarnos y
primero le pregunto qué es exactamente
la flor ona y aunque no es una
enfermedad nueva deberíamos preocuparnos
en esta etapa de la pandemia
buenas tardes básicamente es la
posibilidad de una coinfección es decir
que una persona al mismo tiempo voy a
tener la infección por el virus de la
influenza por el virus del sars co2 y
causante lakovic 19 en realidad es algo
que puede suceder y puede ser cuando los
dos virus están circulando porque
desafortunadamente el hecho que esté
infectado con un virus no me estime de
que me quedara el otro vídeo esto hace
que a medida que empieza a bajar la
circulación del harz todos y puede
circular el virus de influenza
desafortunadamente podríamos
contagiarnos de un nuevo el otro o como
en este caso de los dos de las dulces
virus al mismo tiempo bueno ya aprovechó
para preguntarle qué tanto debe
alarmarnos esta nueva variante o micro
porque el número de contagios si es
mucho mayor que no las anteriores pero
no es igual en la tasa de mortalidad que
no crece al mismo ritmo hay quienes
dicen que esta pandemia ya se está
incluso convirtiendo en endemia como
podríamos explicar todo este fenómeno
mira yo creo que hay dos puntos
importantes esta variante
definitivamente es una variante que es
más contagiosa y por eso la rápida y que
un rápido incremento de casos entre los
países donde está circulando esto se da
porque el virus y tiene esa capacidad de
infectar más personas y al parecer
pareciera que no afectan tanto los
pulmones y por esto es menos agresivo
menos virulentas sin embargo no hay que
engañarnos en el sentido en que también
hay que tener en cuenta que hay una
variable adicional y es que muchas
personas están vacunadas también hay que
decir que hay personas que se han
actuado frente a infectarse y
definitivamente lo que sí sabemos es que
las personas que no se han vacunado
cuando se contagian de la variante o
mika tienen más riesgo especializarse y
también de complicarse
pues señor carlos álvarez muchas gracias
por acompañarnos y pasamos a información
económica porque el acuerdo de
asociación económica integral regional
de asia-pacífico el mayor tratado
comercial del mundo hasta la fecha entró
en vigor este fin de semana el pacto
reúne a unos 15 países en un impacto o
en un tratado mejor de magnitudes
históricas
es el mayor acuerdo de libre comercio
del mundo que entró en vigor el primero
de enero la asociación económica e
integral regional conocida como rcp fue
firmada en noviembre de 2020 las
negociaciones comenzaron en 2013 abarca
la región de asia-pacífico y reúne a 15
países firmantes que representan
alrededor del 30 por ciento de la
población mundial y el 30 por ciento del
pib global esto la convierte en la
primera zona económica del mundo por
delante de eeuu y la unión europea la
rcp permite reducir los derechos de
aduana y a veces hasta el 90% de las
mercancías intercambiadas entre sus
signatarios excluyendo los llamados
productos sensibles armoniza y
simplifica las normas de transacción y
la tributación necesarias para
intensificar el comercio en la zona la
rcp podría generar un superávit de más
de 160 mil millones de dólares en 2030
para los países asiáticos este acuerdo
también refuerza el papel clave de china
en la región
pero no sólo quedan ganadores porque
india que recientemente se ha acercado a
eeuu está muy ausente de la asociación
desde entonces las relaciones entre
nueva delhi y beijing se han deteriorado
a finales de 2019 el primer ministro-
narendra modi había decidido abandonar
las negociaciones y mantenerse al margen
de la rcp sin embargo las negociaciones
pueden reanudarse sin nueva delhi lo
solicita por escrito
cambiamos la información en sudáfrica se
produjo un incendio de grandes
magnitudes en la sede del parlamento en
ciudad del cabo
destruyendo oficinas y provocando el
desplome de algunos techos las
autoridades aseguran que la
conflagración inició en uno de los
edificios más antiguos y luego se
trasladó a otros espacios juan pabló
lucumí nos tienen más detalles
el parlamento de sudáfrica amaneció en
llamas
enormes columnas de humo que escapaban
del techo fueron grabadas por decenas de
personas en la madrugada de este domingo
sin reporte de heridos y con la
incertidumbre que generan las causas del
origen de la conflagración ya hay un
arresto y una investigación en marcha en
el techo del edificio se ha derrumbado
por un lado y el fuego se ha extendido
al nuevo montaje según los agentes se
detectaron grandes grietas en la pared
lo que nos preocupa which is of
concerned las cámaras del parlamento
constan de tres secciones en cuyo el
edificio original y más antiguo donde
comenzaron las llamas una edificación
que data de 1884 con el avance del fuego
los bomberos desplegaron rápidamente un
cordón de protección que se extendió
hasta una plaza en donde todavía se
depositaban flores frente a la catedral
de san jorge' por el funeral de este
sábado del arzobispo desmond tutu
todavía estamos investigando lo que
causó el incendio y como el fuego que se
inició en la antigua asamblea se
trasladó luego a la asamblea nacional
creo que hay alguien detenido ahora
mismo y está siendo interrogado pero
tenemos que profundizar más
la ciudad ya había sufrido un incendio
en abril cuando las llamas en la famosa
montaña de la mesa se extendieron por la
biblioteca de la universidad de ciudad
del cabo lugar que albergaba una
colección única de archivos africanos
ciudad del cabo de la sede legislativa
del país pero es pretoria la capital
ejecutiva de sudáfrica el presidente
tenía programado un discurso en la sede
del parlamento el próximo 10 de febrero
ahora con el incendio también se
desconoce el lugar de la intervención
y nos quedamos en el continente africano
al menos dos personas perdieron la vida
este domingo en una nueva jornada de
manifestaciones contra los militares en
sudán según el comité de médicos de
sudán las personas murieron durante las
manifestaciones que se llevaron a cabo
en jartúm y en la localidad de um durman
el mismo comité señala que con estas
muertes la cifra de fallecidos a manos
de las fuerzas de seguridad desde el
golpe de estado de octubre de 2021 hasta
la fecha asciende a 56
así nos despedimos de esta emisión
informativa en france 24 los invitamos a
que se queden con nosotros en nuestra
programación
[Música]